ces artistes on a du fait d'être calmes
au nez ils vont avoir en commun je fais
comme je disais de parler de leur
quotidien et en fait ils écrivent leur
histoire ils écrivent l'histoire de leur
pays
[Musique]
10 kokam sa part de quelque chose
d'assez simple finalement de
dictionnaires camourenais puisque comme
j'ai dit à traire mes études donc j'ai
beaucoup très avec beaucoup d ouvrages
sur la scène française la scène
italienne etc et là par contre arrivé au
moment des recherches sur le cameroun va
y avait pas des dictionnaires sur la
scène artistique camerounaise dans les
expositions ou dans les articles les
interviews on va toujours voir les mêmes
artistes partagent ni togo justin gaga
salifou lindou etc et c'est à mon avis
ce qui fait que la scène est peu
représentée alors qu'elle est vraiment
extrêmement talentueux
[Musique]
q
on
[Musique]
va avoir des médecins des ingénieurs qui
vont se retrouver call box donc la vente
des abonnements téléphone ou alors
benskineurs donc c'est vraiment ces
motos taxis et donc c'est pour ça qu'on
va retrouver tous les attributs de ces
métiers de ré finalement de leur passion
et qui pourront certainement jamais
exercée en tout cas aucun bruit
[Musique]
c'est toute une pensée une émotion de
l'enfermement de la frustration
qu'est ce qu'il va advenir de ce petit
garçon s'il grandit en fait dans ce
genre d'environnement ce qui est le cas
pour beaucoup de jeunes enfants etc
voilà toute une réflexion sur vince
dépendant de l'environnement peut
totalement créé des adultes épanouis où
les adultes brisé
[Musique]
j'utilise des perles dans mon travail
car ma mère et bamiléké donc au cameroun
si on a un travail ancestral du père
l'âge on perles en fait des meubles des
objets royaux souvent et j'ai décidé de
dévoyer
cette technique pour parler des êtres
humains car j'estime que les êtres
humains sont les vrais bijoux
[Musique]